I've got a bit of a puzzle for you and
it's a puzzle which defeated me I'm in
the lecture theatre where the famous
Italian chemist and writer Primo levy
was student and professor a party who
brought me here said look we have this
periodic table it was installed here 10
years after lady's death as a memorial
to him and she said I'm really quite
embarrassed there's a mistake on it so I
am my colleagues who here with me Simon
Darren looked at this periodic table and
we discovered two things which are not
mistakes but which showed that it's an
old periodic table things that have
changed since 1997 elements that have
changed their name but we couldn't find
the mistake can you